last summer my family night visited
Russia even though none of us go to read
Russian we did not have any trouble in
figuring our way out
all thanks to Google's real-time
translation of Russian boards into
English this is just one of the several
applications of neural networks neural
networks form the base of deep learning
a subfield of machine learning where the
algorithms are inspired by the structure
of the human brain neural networks take
in data train themselves to recognize
the patterns in this data and then
predict the outputs for a new set of
similar data let's understand how this
is done let's construct a neural network
that differentiates between a square
circle and triangle neural networks are
made up of layers of neurons these
neurons are the core processing units of
the network first we have the input
layer which receives the input the
output layer predicts our final output
in between exist the hidden layers which
perform most of the computations
required by our network here's an image
of a circle this image is composed of 28
by 28 pixels which make up for 784
pixels each pixel is fed as input to
each neuron of the first layer neurons
of one layer are connected to neurons of
the next layer through channels each of
these channels is assigned a numerical
value known as weight the inputs are
multiplied to the corresponding weights
and their sum is sent as input to the
neurons in the hidden layer each of
these neurons is associated with a
numerical value called the bias which is
then added to the input sum this value
is then passed through a threshold
function called the activation function
the result of the activation function
determines if the particular neuron will
get activated or not an activated neuron
transmits data to the neurons of the
next layer over the channels in this
manner the data is propagated through
the network this is called forward
propagation in the output layer the
neuron with the highest value fires and
determines the output the values are
basically a probable
for example here are near unassociated
with square has the highest probability
hence that's the output predicted by the
neural network of course just by a look
at it
we know our neural network has made a
wrong prediction but how does the
network figure this out
note that our network is yet to be
trained during this training process
along with the input our network also as
the output fed to it the predicted
output is compared against the actual
output to realize the error in
prediction the magnitude of the error
indicates how wrong we are in the sign
suggests if our predicted values are
higher or lower than expected the arrows
here give an indication of the direction
and magnitude of change to reduce the
error this information is then
transferred backward through our network
this is known as back propagation now
based on this information the weights
are adjusted this cycle of forward
propagation and back propagation is
iteratively performed with multiple
inputs this process continues until our
weights are assigned such that the
network can predict the shapes correctly
in most of the cases this brings our
training process to an end
you might wonder how long this training
process takes honestly neural networks
may take hours or even months to train
but time is a reasonable trade-off when
compared to its scope let us look at
some of the prime applications of neural
networks facial recognition cameras on
smartphones these days can estimate the
age of the person based on their facial
features
this is neural networks at play first
differentiating the face from the
background and then correlating the
lines and spots on your face to a
possible age forecasting neural networks
are trained to understand the patterns
and detect the possibility of rainfall
or arise and stock prices with high
accuracy music composition neural
networks can even learn patterns and
music and train itself enough to compose
a fresh tune so here's a question for
you which of the following statements
does not hold true
activation functions are threshold
functions B error is calculated at each
layer of the neural network see both
forward and back propagation take place
during the training process of a neural
network D most of the data processing is
carried out in the hidden layers leave
your answers in the comments section
below three of you stand a chance to win
Amazon vouchers so don't miss it with
deep learning and neural networks we are
still taking baby steps the growth in
this field has been foreseen by the big
names companies such as Google Amazon
and Nvidia have invested in developing
products such as libraries predictive
models and intuitive GPUs that support
the implementation of neural networks
the question dividing the visionaries is
on the reach of neural networks to what
extent can we replicate the human brain
we'd have to wait a few more years to
give a definite answer but if you
enjoyed this video it would only take a
few seconds to like and share it also if
you haven't yet do subscribe to our
Channel and hit the bell icon as we have
a lot more exciting videos coming up fun
learning till then
you